I am shopping mall here in San Diego a
bit of shopping
where we plan to play some golf very
nice town here lots of restaurants
friendly people helping us find our way
a beautiful weather and a lot nicer than
Vancouver and these weather wise and
here we have some you know local eatery
seconds
yeah wow he moves around hallelujah get
the cheer up dr. America zero black how
about you I've alternate are you two
went on to mahahm troubles oh my gosh hi
there here it is San Diego raining we
came down here to play golf at is
raining i still have my flu i tried to
upload my videos yesterday but for some
reason youtube now won't let me so it
may have to do with fact there was a
message somewhere about someone trying
to access your account from a different
location I mean all of these security
measures they put in are just so
annoying i'm going to see if I can do it
via Dropbox to Alex in our office in
Vancouver see if he can upload the
videos but if it rains I'll just have
more time for studying Korean and we'll
talk to you later bye